[Music]
Welcome Friends to another episode of
top five Skyrim mods of the week I am
your friend cam this is your friend Seb
and there's also Kevin vanor it's taking
three years for us to become friends not
just your hosts no no I believe well
we've met so many of you now some of you
so I feel like we're friends we bonded
i' like to yeah speaking of friends one
of our good friends uh wrote into us I
way you said friends there was quite
like one of our friends no this guy is
awesome Isaac Isaac grer um is our fan
feature this week he sent us a few weeks
ago I think it was this really nice line
drawing of of Kevin vanord and the
chicken and the emblem in the background
it's it's perfect it's absolutely super
praise well I'm a I'm a big fan of this
kind of drawing and he's absolutely
nailed it uh there's Kevin stood in his
family portrait pose with the chicken
who by the way looks Furious yeah looks
angry which uh yeah it's an absolutely
fastic drawing Kevin's face is shrouded
in Shadow so you can't really it's
actually um it's because Kevin's face is
not you can't draw it it's a bit like
you know in the har you know in the
Harry Potter Universe you can't plot
Hogwarts on a map sure whatever okay
it's the same kind of deal okay you
can't you can't draw Kevin's face you
you draw it and then you're just like
it's just a smudge every time you try it
just ink just rolls off the paper
amazing yeah there you go true fact true
fact speaking about the true fact Seb
let's get to mod number
one it's not a fact it's a mod shut
up Z Kevin's angry at my segue CU he
knows that mods aren't facts look how
angry he is or is is that happy I can't
tell isn't it that is the I assume he's
Furious but this is mod number one and
it's called real bows I can tell because
our bow looks different that's that is
the that is the same Kevin Van bow from
episodes gone by it is wa these ctist
have kindly offered to let us help us
demonstrate these real B pin cushion
bodies so we can demonstrate exactly how
it works there we go yeah perfect yes so
if we have a look at the bow here uh if
Kevin can you draw there you go um it's
much narrower and it's much more like a
real bow it is if you look at the bows
in skm they're generally quite chunky it
was like the art team when they made all
the all the weapons this SC decided they
were going to give for this kind like
chunky fantasy aesthetic which is cool
but a lot of people have since made more
realistic versions oh and it's off is it
going to be hit right in the heart oh
they're very weak in the heart yeah yeah
yeah oh bear bear appears I love that we
are always surprised by the cultist and
the bear even though we load up the same
save every time I know I know I know who
would have thought this going real well
I really like these new bows they who
missed me you say new bows we've only
seen one bow so far okay well I'll tell
you what let's go to a place where we
can craft and have a look at the other
bows Okie doie like Riverwood perfect
for crafting bows it's one of my
favorites actually looks pretty good so
the whole design like ethos Behind These
is that they're realistic yeah that's
that's basically the whole thing all
right s let's have a look at some of
these bows now this first one is the
Kevin vano which we've discovered is the
orcish bow so looks very different does
have any of the kind of green um orcish
kind of stylings the orcish design has
always been quite like rugged and sort
of slapped out very sharp and um and
rough and I like this one's actually
really neat what about the force worn B
let's have a look uh that's kind of
funny it's like it's got like two parts
to it there we go wielding the force wor
bow well I'm no bow expert thought I get
told that every single day uh but I
don't know how having two bows basically
back to back makes for a better bow so
that first one is really redundant
surely well given how much uh fans of
this show knew about swords there must
be an archery expert out there explain
this bow please it looks it certainly
looks cool maybe it's just for flare
that looks cool it's huge yeah
definitely a lombo of sorts yeah I guess
you can get crazy distance but man
that's that's a bit that looks a bit
nuts so it's only replaced the vanilla
ones and by that I mean the non-dlc bows
so the dragon bone bow is the same um
the Nordic bow for example that's the
same as well so uh but it it has changed
you know the for sworn bow and the
hunting bow and the Nord hero bow
basically like all the ones from the
vanilla game that you can't even craft
so they're all
[Music]
good welcome Seb to Markarth and mod
number two now we your hate for Markarth
is well known in oh yes but why are we
here then considering how much you hate
it uh because all of the people in marar
like to Swan around uh because they
think themselves super fancy and they
Swan around wearing fancy jewelry do
they yes I hate them I've decided that
they do okay and so this mod is called
immersive jewelry which massively
massively UPS the amounts of jewry
massively massively massively massive
and the reason it massively massively
UPS the amount of jewelry is because it
is a compilation mod of a bunch of
different jewelry mods out there so it's
it bundles them all together in one
adding about three and a half thousand
odd New pieces of jewelry what crazy so
where are they oh in the jewelry section
it might be in the jewelry section n now
you're just crazy so I mean they're not
they're not you know Enchanted or
anything but of course you could just
make one enchant it yourself depends how
you fancy dressing up your character and
Kevin has always been aesthetically
minded oh yeah I mean just look at it
all right let's have a look at some of
this jewelry we just got for Kevin he is
Keen yep headband he's give him a
headband as well lace bread and
headband his eyebrows seem to clip
through it it's just glued on yeah I
like that that's good um uh the steel
Empire necklace oh yeah let's get that
to go oh wow oh I like that it oh it
attaches still like it is yeah looks
like it attaches it's actually two of
them he's just yeah he's blinged up
that's good that's good and what else do
we get we got some
earrings uh which have totally not
worked no they really haven't where are
those earrings no he doesn't want to
wear them he's like no I've got enough
got enough jewelry on already well he
may not want to wear them but uh you can
look at them here and I guess there's
far more there's far more bits of
jewelry like that around which you can
then sell do you reckon uh what would
happen if you Dro that it's funny cuz
there's so huge here and you drop him
and the boink there you go
a don't step on my jewelry all right I I
can fixy you I can fix
this there we go nailed it yeah all
right let's uh zoom in enhance ow ow
what's going on guys we're just we're
just humble jewelry Smiths leave us
alone what happened to his clothes why
is he naked because he too was sporting
jewelry I suppose it's the smug Mar
carians last guy h bie b huh yeah bie B
I feel like you w w you I won that fight
you won that fight well done sir oh dear
that's a that's a terrible place to die
didn't realize he was a naked God it was
just a naked dude but the least
important thing is there's our jewelry
in fact oh God more importantly yeah
look how look how well it blends with
the blood blood spattered ground yeah
really really
beautiful welcome sep to mod number
three which you're welcome which this
week is another akavar house now it's we
have shown off a akavar state before
sure have in the classic episode Samurai
hot tub party that was a great episode I
remember the hot tub was the best bit
yeah it was but what's this one called
exactly well this is nakahara akavar
house so smaller uh a little more quaint
I think you could argue uh and it's been
designed with the aesthetic of the
aavaran mind so it's very
Japanese in its design aesthetic not
just outside but inside as well outside
it really sticks out in this in the
normal Tundra if you look at it it's
like suddenly there's these cherry
blossoms and this kind akavar style
house mhm and uh complete with rabbits
and Dead bears dead dead animals of of
All Sorts let's go
indoors now I thought it had been quite
a while since we'd shown off a uh a good
oldfashioned player home and this one uh
breaks the basic law a little bit so
it's kind of a questionable law tie in
not just breaking law but breaking
standard rules of safety having an open
flame in what is essentially a wooden
paper house that's just dumb oh more of
them you I'm not on board with this mod
at all you have to be a true expert o an
enchanting workbench use it it it
reminds me very much of the enchanting
uh table of of of the past I love that
Kevin's still naked I know yeah let's
put some put some damn clothes on Kevin
no keep him naked okay fair enough fair
enough it's the samurai way Samurai way
apparently ah this is cool armor but
armor you can't wear which always makes
me sad Place Ebony Blade you do not have
an Ebony Blade place you do not have
dragon P you are a terrible
Samurai so uh we've seen these kind of
things before where it's it's a nice way
of storing your items make it look like
they're all piled in so it's really
quite small like that's it that's that's
all the house you've got your entryway
here I know there something off to the
left there dangerous candle you got your
cooking place you've got your your basic
uh alamy lab poers stuff you know your
enchanting
table if you crack open a torch I think
you'll you'll be able to see a lot more
really yeah because the the lighting's
always really bad oh man I think we're
done all right look at that I like that
you have a little bonsai tree as well
yeah it's it's really nice oh a
bookshelf complete with no books yeah
well it's your home to craft as you will
yeah exactly exactly I think it's really
good I like the artwork I think the
thing that makes it most suitable is
that it's in such a peaceful local yeah
over by the lake I liked how the reads
were um boldly poking through the the
decking out the front indeed oh switch
armor I guess it depends on the armor
that you're displaying did it did it
switch the display
armor ah yeah yeah yeah it's female
armor that's good so you can customize
it to show armor for your character
that's
good welcome Seb to mod number four
Kevin is still mostly naked that's cuz
he's got some crafting to do it's his
favorite way to craft yeah yet more
crafting that was just ignore the giant
ignore the giant guard he he there he's
there patrolling keeping White Run safe
now um what this model allows you to do
um is craft gold coins from gold ingots
which if you think about it is quite a
nice idea for mod because I mean you
could you could be carrying around loads
of big ingots but be broke and it makes
sense you'd be able to uh chop that up
into currency exactly and I mean you
could of course in the vanilla game you
can sell gold ingots
but they only sell for about 25 gold and
if you think about that you're like well
that's actually a pretty crappy trade
although this is actually a worst trade
no it's not uh you get 100 gold pieces
for a single Ingot it's oh 100 gold I
thought it was one gold we were getting
no it's you get a hundred of them oh
that's much better so when you get this
mod what you what you can do is you
choose the value that a single Ingot
will will yield so was that done in the
installation process so no you actually
have to choose which you drop into your
data folder so what I did was I went
with 100 cuz I thought that was probably
the most law friendly but of course
that's only one half of how this mod
Works Cameron oh really because what if
you say needed a gold ingot in order to
craft something very specific but you
only had gold coins well of course you'd
go over to the smelter which is right
behind you and you could uh smelt
yourself down a gold ingot shoving all
your money yep so I guess go down to MK
again and we can go and find a
Goldsmith's Ingot there it is there you
go and it requires 150 gold so you shov
all your gold mhm and you out comes a
Goldsmith Ingot I've just noticed the
value of the Goldsmith's Ingot is 500
gold which makes this a terrible trade
oh it's a terrible trade yes but you uh
so I thought it sold for like 25 gold
this might have changed because of the
uh there's some interesting stuff going
on with immersive jewelry yeah so wait
that means we pay 150 gold and we get
500 worth 500 gold out of it yeah but
then when we when we craft gold coins
out of anot we get a a worse we get a
worse deal by a by a factor of 500 by a
factor five but I reckon as you say
that's conflict in mods but uh yeah who
knows who knows it's annoying you can't
drop gold Want To Make It Rain I can do
with these Make It
Rain wait what why didn't rain yep
where'd it go well that was an expensive
experiment I thought I just dropped it
but I don't see it did I maybe I didn't
no I totally dropped it wow someone is
going to trip over that and have a great
day maybe they're absolutely tiny we
just don't realize the smallest gold is
there it
is that's hilarious I like that okay
Make It Rain Kevin is it raining uh the
frame rate certainly
suffering I can hear one one single coin
there they are oh they spawning it's
less of a rain more more of a spawn you
know what will actually make this rain
oh of
course whoa making
rain you're welcome White
Run watch out Jerkins don't get in the
way of this goal if one of those hit you
in the face of the force that goes at
really painful that's a good way to go
we're going to be finding these coins
for
days probably completely ruining uh
White Run's economy as the trade Hub of
Skyrim oh well but well worth
[Music]
doing so welcome to the final mod of
today are we here already it's animated
dragon wings it's a userv voted mod and
it won it did indeed it won like quite a
bit actually I'm not surprised this was
the second week it's been in there but
we have actually done the similar mod
before way back in the episode attack of
the zombie Nicholas Cage what an episode
it was yeah before our faces were on
Skyrim mod just our voices
why would we need our faces when we had
Nicholas C I know that was that that
face mask that you'd find and he would
quote Nicholas Cage things it was
brilliant yeah it was really good still
the Declaration of Independence that was
it yeah um but yeah so back then we also
in that episode showcased a mod called
dragon wings and uh it was all right it
looked a bit dumb dragon wing wearable
dragon wings unfolded yes they just
these static unfolded wings but this
this mod animates those type of wings so
uh you have to come to a cooking pot to
cook up some potions we're going to miss
cook up some wings yeah you got to cook
up some some tasty chicken wings and
well actually instead of it's danger
dragon wings how many dragon wings can
you eat oh too many too many but if you
look you make these kind of cool potions
and uh once you have them we've already
made a bunch if we uh run back over here
we can see what happens when you drink
them whoa and there they go and on they
hop so uh the animation really cool oh
it doesn't allow us the ability to fly
but they do change dep depending on what
you're doing so when you're running we
can H you H you hover a little bit
that's really good uh when you sprint
when you swim they'll help you swim
through the water at a greater pace so
I'm not sure this is deep enough yeah it
will be there we
go all right that's a little a little
bit of extra swimming assistance that's
kind of dumb this has got a real um
Legacy of cane feel for it to me like
yeah have you ever play Legacy of Kane
with razel uh no I did not you never
played Legacy of Kane I didn't I didn't
surpris I'm sorry uh one thing that is
pretty cool with this uh is when you
crouch okay let me and they'll defend
you and if you go in first person as
well when you're crouched you'll see
that they come in into your view to
defend you keep you hidden awesome so a
look at Kevin soaring through the woods
he kind of he's like a very very well
jeweled up Batman he is it's exactly
what he
is Kevin Kevin man can you take me
higher yes I can to high frothgar all
right now let's remove These Wings yeah
na these ones off they're great but you
know evil wings so oh wow this is where
the oh yes I think the evil works with
that armor the best very well very very
very neat I agree oh look at him look at
Kevin it's just focus and determination
he does look very evil that is
absolutely the most appropriate one for
Kevin yeah all righty let's go Kevin big
jump big jump big
jump okay it's this sort of
works and then after a while swooping
Zone you get oh it does
yeah it's quite subtle but it is there I
think it's a pretty good Shear drop
here oh yeah it is more of like a as you
say a gliding Batman esque Aid than
anything else the the Buzz Light Year of
the Dragon Wing world yeah
there we go oh
no
ah God come on ow ow yes here we go big
big big
fly it's a shame that there's not more
of a sort of like a forward momentum to
this if only was a way to uh blast
ourselves high in the air with wings on
ah these chickens ought to help us out
yeah I'm sure they will uh let's uh what
do we let's just punch just punch Kevin
vanau
surely uh
boom oh did you blow the Wings off you
oh there they are yeah they just took a
while so Kevin choosing not to deploy
the wings which is interesting it's okay
I I think maybe much like a fighter jet
he's got them in uh in lean mode so he
can get extra speed he has seem to have
uh flown oh he's Landing right next to
little bounce yeah oh right on his feet
that was
amazing well SE those wings were
definitely an improvement on the last
wings from that
they were a massive Improvement not not
only because of the animations
especially the
little uh but I was looking there and
the uh the old mod the wings are really
tiny they really are they're they're
kind of like you know when you get a
fancy dress uh wings that you put on
your back and they barely cross your
shoulders yeah I I thought it was just
those wings which now moved but they're
completely new U they've done really
well and it they really gave me that
Legacy of C Vibe I want to know if
anyone else had that as well I'm sure
there's a good mod combination of uh of
you know flight mods and and variations
that could make that those wings work
perfectly also I bet you could get um
Raziel from Legacy Kan you could build
him with those wings now in Skyrim and
that might look quite awesome um Ral I
never know how to pronounce it let me
know anyway s we've asked a lot of
questions this this week but uh let's
answer some of them right now good plan
rather actually in fact these aren't
questions these aren't questions they
are comments from our question of last
week yeah um so last week Lucy was
inundated after the episode with
potential business Endeavors involving
her surname so thank you so much for
that um so remember if you didn't watch
we asked people to uh come up with
because we are we have the CRA blog and
the re ready sebie blog and she Lucy was
annoyed that she didn't have one and uh
we were like well what about Lucy James
gains and it could be a Blog about
weightlifting and then everyone else has
sent her like a million we had a lot of
different so let's read a few of them
out um starting with k Trin I I think
that's right I think it's just Trin I
imagine the H Trin and they say at Lucy
James buy your guns at Lucy James aims
which is very good A lot of these by the
way we got multiple versions of so
apologies if we don't have your name
listed as the person who came up with it
but like uh some of them were very very
popular uh the next one we had was from
uh Dan Beaver heart presumably he has
the heart of a beaver and the soul of a
beaver extra Nimble and he loves trees
um so he came up with uh Lucy's
landscape business Lucy James terrain I
like Lucy James terrains that's good
Alex that kaggy Alex who regular watch
of the show say who we met at the scarm
line indeed say wishing Lucy luck with
her new Walking sck business Lucy James
KES very good James kanes I read it
wrong uh Brandon wheeler came up with uh
your new propit blog Lucy James
proclaims that's my favorite that's my
favorite really good and then frea F
said ly James I think you should carry
on Kevin Van nord's Decap
Legacy through Lucy James mes that was a
very popular one Lucy James mes was very
good uh and then we also had uh Lucy
James stains Lucy's new stain removal
blog from uh tremal so that was pretty
good and then cam do you want to uh feel
the last one well no there was two more
there was um oh no sorry there was just
one more um she's a vampire Lucy James
veins which is a strange one just what a
vampire business right yeah just
professional vampire it could be her
private surgery yeah I guess I guess
yeah um but we did have one uh one
comment this like un Lucy James related
comment from Brian e renar and they he
says yes ah Skyrim where you can catch
salmon with bare hands but can't smash
1,000 year old locks Y and uh I think we
both retweeted this and a lot of people
replied and they really like that
comment so Ked that was a really nice
really nice touch I really like that uh
and then onwards we've got the uh the
vote I suppose yes
yes this week up for the vote for the
fifth mod next week's episode we you
could have gambling Dwarven three row
slot machine which we put in last week
we had last week yeah uh and it yeah it
was suggested to us and I was like H I
know gambling yeah I suppose that could
work yeah easy second so if you want to
see that in it goes uh cam the next one
alternatively you could have Dave the
Talking Dragon Companion Pet that I mean
that's what I call a dragon sounds good
like has anyone seen Dave no he's he's
eating a cow that's what they should
have that's what they should have called
the dragons in Game of Thrones Dave just
Dave yeah just Dave uh and then of
course the last mod you could vote for
is lost long swords if you lost your
long sword Fe not vote for lost long
swords we've been doing a lot of weapons
mods lately so
uh I'll I'll keep that one on the mental
back burner should it lose but uh I'm a
I'm a big fan of these the confidence
you've got there in Lost long swords
chances should it lose which I hope I
hope wins but I you know as much as I
hope that the others win I do all right
Seb time for the Choose Your Own
Adventure let me let me recap yes last
week cuz we're going through this this
period in the narrative where Kevin is
reminiscing about how he first met cow
he does remin Kevin said to C kill all
humans and then C replied and you guys
decided yes that he said moo Kevin moo
and this is where our story continues s
do you want to want to give it a read
yes yes this we're going to experience
this together I hope you understand this
is going to be beautiful cam wrote this
I've never seen it okay here we go moo
Kevin moo these words of advice returned
to Kevin's head now they said so much
and yet so little Kevin was awoken from
his nostalgic Haze by the sound of heavy
footsteps behind him he spun with the
grace of 10,000 ballerinas to match gaze
with balls nasty the orc I heard you
were in sste looking for me his spalls
nasty Kevin gritted his teeth and with
the noise it shook the birds from the
surrounding trees
if we were to do this let's get this
fight over with Bulls nasty proclaimed
drawing his orcish great sword Kevin
nodded and reached into his inventory
his eyes never leaving those of Ball's
nasty with an expression which hinted at
a rice smile Kevin withdrew a weapon
from his backpack the orc's demeanor
rapidly changed as he caught a glimpse
of the weapon Kevin Now brandished Kevin
leapt into a fighting stance
brandishing I he used brandishing twice
whoops whoops wielding wielding Kevin Le
into a fighting stance wielding spinning
rapidly a yeah what was he wielding was
it the Kevin Van sword which we've seen
before was it the Kevin Van BAU was it
of course his fists uh you know a big
favorite of Kevin's uh the dri Dooms or
of course Cameron the vote to self time
what was he wielding yes it's up to you
you can vote by going to Tiny url.com
for / camra blog and we should have said
if you want to vote on the mods which we
just talked about then you go to
tinyurl.com
ready blog absolutely so sebbi blog Fraz
blog frazzy blog and just go to both of
them go both required on both parts vot
till your heart vote till your heart's
content please do so excellent the Kevin
Van sword the van BAU the fists the
Dooms or the boat to Soul Ste I'm pretty
keen on though um the the final one I
like idea ofing inventory just coming up
like this his fist and the going yeah uh
oh God
yeah that's funny um but it's up to you
and uh we'll find out next week what
happens when Kevin and blls nasty
finally get the fight on excellent well
Seb that brings us to the end of another
episode of top five scy doeses it does
it's nice to uh to revisit some some
player homes we haven't had one in a
while and also kind of a new version of
a crappy mod we was shorted way back
when yes uh and I I was also glad that
we finally got the uh the gold to coins
coins to Gold mod in because I feel like
that could have been a very easy Den
even though the you know much like when
you travel abroad the the kind of
conversion rate awful is just terrible
that was my you can change that you have
that power exactly okay and you also
have the power to come back next week
and watch another episode of top five
Skyes the week we'll see you
[Music]
then